Koni we manufacture elevators escalators
auto walks and doors all of these
devices are streams of data that we are
collecting in order to process those
streams we need a scalable way of handle
the amount of data that is coming in and
that's where cloud function fits in
perfectly we handle that data with
event-driven architecture we use
functions to persist that data and to
generate further events on that data
that are then utilized and consumed by
applications and our customers and users
in our analytics platform we analyzed
the set of data and we generate value
predictive in a sense that we can
predict the failure rate to a certain
percentage that is about to happen in
the future for our equipment and this
allows us to perform predictive
maintenance and this is kind of the
whole concept that we have behind our
24/7 connected services which is a
promise to our customers that the
equipment is connected to the cloud and
we are monitoring it and that's where we
generate the real a value for our
customer from me mr. Spector at the
moment we use almost all aspects of the
IBM cloud we use storage from the cloud
we use cloud function we use messaging
services we use IOT services so a number
of services already in use and platform
and that use will only grow as our
digital footprint in in the industry
grows
[Music]